i brought the beautiful youtube
sensation
is here to say hello
all you gotta do is tweet us
use the hashtag
vip and i'll hook you up with the
tickers who's going to tweet let me see
your answers
hey guys how's it going i'm hanging out
here with ellie golding and you just got
off the stage here at hangout fest how
are you feeling
feel pretty high feels pretty good yeah
you just got done with your european
tour are you heading anywhere next are
you done for a little while we head to
nashville to do a headline show tomorrow
and then i head home and then i have
other festivals in the uk and so on and
so forth yeah actually i believe you're
heading to my hometown of pittsburgh are
you with bruno mars i'll be with bruno
yeah we're touring we start at the end
of june so yeah it's exciting i always
see you post tons of instagrams what's
your favorite app of all time i'm
killing it on the instagram right now
you are i mean i think i saw you had
with all the orange server thingy yeah
like
i i genuinely um the other day i was
like i have so many instagram
followers i don't know why because most
of the photos are really just i don't
know photos of me
being stupid and like boring stuff but
people seem to like that stuff so they
just like get yourself a good filter and
yeah do you have a favorite filter
x-pro x-prime i usually use mayfair yeah
that's my favorite i think it's one of
the newer ones they just expo is the is
like is the one the go-to one yeah
should we can we take it yeah okay all
right
ready guys already
alright that's it for my hangout
festivities
oh i'm so funny i'm gonna go i love you
guys bye